we have to turn it back into krump
I know well can we just take a moment to
acknowledge what's happening here please
I mean Captain Underpants is hanging out
of that treehouse
well a hero's work is never done now it
is time to fly again no no no no no what
where are my pants
oh no he's gruff again ah Rolo that's it
now we know it turns on back and forth
turns who what why am i soaking wet Hey
oh just promised up yeah we probably
should that's without doing this Rollo
huh I am captain hood what are you good
hello well hello you're not ah no I what
is happening right now I don't know
let's try and leave and see what happens
wow that's an expensive door mm-hmm the
studio that brought you Shrek Kung Fu
Panda and Madagascar hi I'm Jorge beer
this is my best friend Harold Hutchins
we just make comics and try to make each
other laugh and this old guy is mr. crup
George
he's the worst principal in the world
ever since you've attended his school
he's been responsible for one prank
after another
some of those must have been really hard
to pull off like that tiger or that
tiger was crazy
ah I told you I would get you one day
I'm going to have you to place its SAP
miss Glasson we're going to annihilate
the friendship huh don't you do
something
put the ping down mr. crup or will
hypnotize you my fingers you will obey
our every command Rolo I didn't think
it'd happen this summer come sidekick we
gotta stop him haha why thank you
vehicle person oh yeah which probably
will get him their greatest creation
Captain Underpants you can't actually
fly I take to the sky like an awesome
wow he is super dumb Jimmie's now their
biggest problem stags down you monster
[Music]
based on the worldwide phenomenon
higher-class a new core no danger not
some scary guy with a secret evil agenda
guys I totally got this
totally he's got it Kevin Hart Ed Helms
Thomas Middleditch Nick Kroll
when it's cut all together like that you
really get a sense of the scope
DreamWorks Captain Underpants pour so
you're trapped in some sort of invisible
box like prison is it okay that I'm kind
of loving this yep enough I will shut
you breathe Oh Mosley yet
[Music]
so
[Music]